vous le savez le gouvernement a fait des
efforts sans précédent pour renforcer
les moyens mis à votre disposition et je
voudrais vous annoncer
monsieur directeur ici ce matin à dijon
que dès la rentrée
vous serez renforcée d'une vingtaine
d'effectifs supplémentaires
c'est logique c'est nécessaire et cette
la matérialisation au delà des bonnes
paroles de notre volonté déterminée je
veux dire aussi représentant de
l'institution judiciaire ayant consacré
avant-hier en déplacement dans un
tribunal qu'il nous faudra aussi de la
même manière accélérée renforcer les
moyens dévolus à cette institution car
une réponse ou judiciaire rapide et
adapté
j'en suis parfaitement conscient est
absolument indispensable pour couronner
l'efficacité de votre action